[Music]
the the truth about the matter is that
if I had different people in my ear at
that time it would not had made that
decision no her first response is my
friends made me do it and I do
appreciate her being honest I really do
but I also wanted to point out how women
it's like our first response is to blame
somebody else and not ourselves again
it's a lack of accountability well I had
to divorce him we didn't fight equally
and you you see the simps co-signing
this behavior and this is the problem
ladies these guys never tell you the
truth they are so deceptive they are
dishonest and Men hear the things we say
they process it and they come to a
conclusion if that make sense or it
doesn't make sense but most men will not
tell you when it doesn't make sense and
you see her on this podcast and and
they're kind of coddling her they're
saying oh this makes me happy instead of
saying well why did